vous avez fait de la chirurgie
esthétique et vous assumez complètement
exactement donc oui moi j'ai fait la
chirurgie esthétique plusieurs fois si
je dois dire j'ai fait de la chirurgie
esthétique parce que j'étais complexée
et je me suis posé la question pendant
de nombreuses aller pour moi c'était un
poids donc j'ai refusé tout simplement
de vivre avec ce point-là c'était une
question personnelle fait de la
chirurgie c'était parce que je l'entends
c'était un poids mais en même temps vous
intégrer y est un système qui est la
télé où il fallait peut-être mais les
autres la première chose que j'ai fait
c'est tes seins j'avais 23 ans je
faisais pas de souci n'hésitez
pas du tout la terre était venu beaucoup
plus tard à l'âge de 26 ans j'en ai fait
parce que déjà adolescente je voyais des
jeunes filles qui avaient des voix très
très plate et c'est quelque chose qui me
complexe et je n'arrivais pas à vivre
avec ça quand j'essaie de mettre des
robes vous quoi qui était moulante pas
forcément ça allait pas parce que je
n'aimais pas ce que je refais tes
c'était quelque chose qui était
difficile pour moi à vivre donc plus
tard à l'âge adulte j'ai pris cette
décision là j'ai sauté le pas alors si
c'est pas indiscret vous avez fait
plusieurs opérations bien sûr j'en ai
fait trois qui sont alors j'ai fait la
chirurgie du nez
j'ai fait la poitrine et j'ai fait aussi
le vent ce qu'on appelle une liposuccion
alors vous avez la gentillesse de me
donner voilà la photo avant vos
opérations et après vous vous sentez
aujourd'hui mieux vous dites que vous
voilà alors aujourd'hui je me sens des
vous trouvez belle
je me trouve plus belle charmante vous
êtes très très jolie
tu as pas de raison d'être complexée si
la personne est complexée complexée si
dans sa tête et elle doit trouver sa
solution pas forcément la chirurgie mais
sa solution pour quand vous entendez
Dylan Thierry dire qu'il a dépensé
pratiquement 50000 € c'est indécent
avec vous me la prendre et tu vois pas
en fait
plutôt les voleurs
j'ai pas l'impression que
j'ai dépensé 50000 € net avec son public
[Musique]
c'est bien pour les femmes parce que
elles sont très perfectionniste mais
c'était sa dernière fois. Ajouter oui
mais ces défauts
mes défauts aussi les
actuellement
[Rires]
vous voyez un visage et vous savez si le
bistouri est passé par là ou pas
professionnel
[Musique]
non non non non non pas du tout
j'ai juste un truc à dire parce que
depuis tout à l'heure on parle de
complexe de complexe c'est bien il y en
a qui vraiment des vraies complexes mais
sauf que là on pas dans les excès de la
chirurgie de la médecine esthétique et
c'est là où il y a pas suffisamment de
prévention par rapport au jeune fille ou
jeune garçon qui justement ça l'enfer
permettre moi qui ai subi ma première
esthétique avant faire de la téléréalité
peut-être que les gens qui a été ou
aujourd'hui les moyens de pouvoir faire
de la chirurgie esthétique et peut-être
que c'était difficile moi
personnellement il a fallu que je trouve
un arrangement avec le chirurgien pour
payer en plusieurs fois